how much do you pay for your garden
electric
you're joking
you are joking me we've come to pay your
bills for the year my guy
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions but
on this video this is not going to be a
regular q a sunday because i'm in a
celebration removed and i'm going to be
giving gifts and all kinds of crazy
surprises in this video it's going to
blow you away and this is a celebration
because we've just hit
250 000 subscribers
and honestly it means the world to me
thank you so much for being a subscriber
i think i'm probably the
longest standing property youtuber in
the uk i've been doing this now for six
years i've been full-time investing in
property for
14 years and and doing youtube for six
so i'm in a really good mood today and
i'll tell you something some of you guys
asking me questions and stuff
watch for the answers gonna be some
surprises coming so let's see what we
got this week so
how do you find a list of investors
to sell your deals to number one social
media here's a really cool tip about
social media if you're on instagram if
you um put something on your story but
you tag me in your story and you kind of
make it you're going to bait me right so
you can say something on instagram
that's kind of going to make me like it
but at the same time you're also
reaching out to investors maybe i
reshare it to my hundred thousand
followers on instagram bang so be clever
on social media don't spam add value um
also go down to networking events
networking events when you're trying to
find investors when you go to networking
events rather than going out and going
here's my card here's my card here's my
card here's my card what you should be
doing is you should be saying can i have
your card can i have your card collect
your database the bigger the list the
bigger your bank
next what would you do with ten thousand
pounds i'd put it into rent to rent
is it worth
rent to
for a studio flat is brighton still a
good location for rent-to-service
accommodation
yes brighton's banging
must all hmos have a communal area or
can you also let the living room out for
more income
you need a communal area if the bedrooms
are less than 100 square feet
if the bedrooms are 100 square feet or
more then you do not need a communal
area bang
next when using investors money for brr
what is the process for paying them back
do you ever refinance to pay them back
or is it strictly buy the next property
yeah that's normally the way normally
buy a house use someone else's money add
value refinance and then upon the
refinance you pay them back and you can
structure this as a joint venture
agreement like a partnership or you can
do it as a straight alone agreement
what are your top tips at dealing with
purchasing properties at auction
purchasing properties at auction make
sure that you view the property make
sure you get a survey on the property
make sure that you study the legal pack
make sure that you work out the maximum
that you can bid is and don't go a penny
above it and never get emotionally
attached use your formulas not your
feelings next what would you advise i
live in a council property and i have
the right to buy bang congratulations
i get the full discount of 116 000
pounds but not currently working are
there any ways of getting around that to
be able to get the mortgage yeah you
need to do whatever it freaking takes to
get the mortgage you need to speak to a
mortgage broker even if you have to go
and get a job go get some part-time work
or maybe you have to move somebody into
the property and put them on the ast for
a year and then like just buy it if
you've got the opportunity to buy 116
000 pounds below the price find a way to
get it use the equity as the deposit and
just
get find a way that's your mission in
life right now
next how do i become a compliant deal
sourcer you don't
you cody or source your first deal and
then you use the profit to then get
compliant really important
what is the best side hustle for
teenagers don't side hustles are for
losers don't get a side hustle you need
to study and understand business and set
up a business this whole concept of side
i saw i really if you're in a job and
your job pays you quite well and you
like your job focus all of your time and
attention on your job and build yourself
up in your job and get you know fine and
then use that money that you're making
to invest or
just leave your job and have a business
side hustles are freaking for losers all
right what is the quickest
strategy to build my current buy to let
portfolio from four properties to 50 in
seoul ownership don't
don't build four properties to 50
properties and sold ownership number one
partner with people joint venture
collaborate if you want to go fast go
alone if you want to go fargo together
secondly i won't be trying to buy 50
houses every deal you do should be
bigger than the last deal so slow
stretch bigger and bigger and partner
with people that's my opinion
what are the best books on property the
best books on property i'm glad you
asked that question i've got a whole
pile of books here i'd recommend on
property stick with these and you'll be
fine um they're all they're all written
by the same author um they're all
written by me
so we got um the secrets of property
development if you want to do property
development buy low rent high if you
want to buy cheap houses and rent them
out as hmos financial freedom in seven
days if you want to do rent to rent and
deal sourcing and also some biographies
there's 13 there's 30 students in here
that are financially free another 30 in
here that are financially free where you
can actually see what other people are
doing
stick with those you'll be just fine
next why do so many people still fail to
succeed in property even after investing
in courses and acquiring knowledge they
need um i think maybe the reason and
some people fail even after reading the
books and going on the courses i think i
would say it's because
knowledge is only 25 of the of the
journey you can get all the knowledge
read all the books and you're still 25
of the way there because you also need
other stuff you need belief you need
courage you need the ability to take
action you need to have a good team
there's lots of other stuff um besides
knowledge but what i would say is if you
if you persist and have knowledge and
take action and keep believing you will
eventually win
okay um
you know what
here's a surprise right now i'm gonna
stop taking questions right now because
here's the thing in order to celebrate
my 250 000 subscribers um i did say i
was going to do a raffle and for all the
all of my subscribers there was going to
be a random raffle pulled and somebody
that spent one pound that's all you have
to invest one pound on attending my
training programs was going to be
entered into the raffle if they were a
subscriber of the channel and i said
that the winner of the raffle
was gonna get their utility bills paid
off for the rest of 2022.
i got a special mixer on my phone which
is this little app which selects
everybody into a raffle you can press
you can press submit and it randomly
picks somebody as the winner and i'm
gonna do that right now live
on this q a sunday video and then
whoever it is is gonna get their utility
bills paid off for the for the rest of
the year it might be you who knows and
i'm actually i'm not just going to pull
it and then ring them up i'm going to
pull it
and then i'm going to arrange to go to
their house okay so i'm going to i'm
just going to turn up with the house so
let's see here we go
and we've got
daniel greenwood daniel i hope you're
watching this daniel i'm coming to your
house daniel lives in
telford
which is
uh from here let me do a route planner
from here
two hours and 17 minutes
should we go
let's go
daniel i'm coming to your house bro
utilities paid off for the rest of 2022.
let's
go this is your cup of tea
[Music]
oh we need to get some money for the
dude we'll just go for the cashback on
the way
let's go i think i've got everything
i've got my car keys
all right let's go
solo
[Music]
you need to come with me
come on let's go
they see me rolling
they hating
patrolling and trying to get me riding
dirty riding dirty
[Music]
trying to find out how much these wigs
are
you get dressed up what about one of
these
could be better oh there we go let's put
it on
please put that is just 30 pounds
30 pounds
oh yeah yeah the 30 pounds is good i'm
ready to pack it up
it's a mirror
oh
yes i love that so much do you have
glasses love big glasses
we have glasses
you draw
sorry sorry
5.99
thank you
do i look like
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
[Applause]
but i'm the greatest
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've got a couple of mansions
yes how much are these bad boys 18 quid
for some reading glasses
seven pound fifth day
[Music]
i'm gonna see if i feel your customers
okay 800 cash that's a hell of a deal
i'm headed downtown
[Music]
all right
uh number is number 10 number 10
oh thank you mate
automatch
hello
how much do you pay for your garden
electric
you're joking
you are joking me
i just pay electric how much do you pay
for your electric about 250 quid a month
oh man choose well
we've come to pay your bills for the
year my guy
i don't think you recognize me through
my disguise man
is
what's good brother
good to see you can we pop in hello
how are you
don't worry
well we had a raffle and and it was
basically the winner of the raffle was
going to win some i was going to win a
prize which would pay utilities for the
year so we got 1200 pounds cash
so that's for you my brother
congratulations
that's what happens that's what happens
when you subscribe to the channel and go
along that's what happens man so
congrats
i'm
dude we just picked this up man from a
wig show it just he saw straight through
it though he was just like oh my gosh
i was like oh man that was 20 pound
badly spent thanks very much good to see
sam 1200 big ones man look i i don't
have to sell my guitars
you play guitar yeah i'm a musician oh
nice bro that's cool can i i'm a
community musician can i have a look at
it i love the acoustic guitar i can play
a few strings myself i can now play a
few strings i'll still do any tunes
that's about all i got man those three
if you can do those three chords you can
play pretty much anything baby
and like a flirt
here's mercy reigns
england
amazing grace
[Music]
i love this guitar